do it
yes
and we're back and we're live let's go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
[Music]
you know let's uh fight for democracy so
make sure you're doing that
anyways I got a lot to talk about Kyrie
Twitter I saw this movie speak no Weevil
I went to Adam Adam Ray's wedding it was
beautiful and we just back in it I hope
you enjoy so everybody Welcome to
all right y'all
what's up everybody thanks for coming to
Richmond with Griffin uh I appreciate
you guys make sure you subscribe hit
that subscribe button so you can get the
notifications so you know what's going
on uh you know I'm usually on Twitch
daily I'll I'll be on Twitch later today
because I got to go do golden hour after
this and if you want to support the show
there's so many ways you can support the
show okay
there's being a YouTube member you could
be a twitch subscriber all right you
could be a patreon subscriber
and something new is subscription on
Instagram too if you just want to
support me you want to get I get you
know get a little extra whatever are you
just you know you're just like yo man I
want to support you I like what you're
doing that's uh different ways you could
do that so I appreciate you guys coming
here every single week it is what it is
um you know anyways
like I say it is voting day
get out and vote if you if be an
informed voter if you're not an informed
voter I actually understand if you
didn't vote you don't want to vote or
you're just like I don't know I I feel
like I'll just be you know just filling
out a ballot for no reason whatever it
is I know voting is difficult it really
does like sometimes it just doesn't make
any sense I personally I feel like
sometimes we voting for things I don't
even think we should be voting for like
the sheriff I mean the sheriff feels
like an interview position you know what
I mean like why are we voting for the
sheriff I don't know this person I don't
know you know I get the mayor the
leadership positions the governor uh but
there's certain positions where I go why
are we voting for that then we have to
vote for judges which I I to me there
should be some sort of panel or
something for judges like I don't know
these people so it is a lot to ask
um
you know to be an informed voter is
tough I'm not gonna lie to you I mean
it's your it's our responsibility to do
that but like I say it you know just in
all practicality it's tough especially
when they're asking us to look up all
this stuff online but we can't vote
online we could pay taxes online but we
can't vote online you know and they
always say like well
you know with the voting the system's
not secure it's not secure it's not safe
well is the money safe is the money
secure how about you send my vote with
the money bet you to get there so I
don't know systems flawed but we're
gonna have to figure out
what is going thanks for being here live
too I see people here alive
um thank you somebody said the the
sheriff holds power no I get that but
what I'm saying it's still like
you know it's like it's a officer of the
law they still are you know what I mean
it just feels like are we qualified to
pick the proper Sheriff how do we decide
is it based off the person's personality
or it's based off like uh uh experience
and knowledge and how are we supposed to
know that based off commercials how do
we know that this person is experienced
enough you know you know what I mean
it's kind of like you know hiring an NFL
coach or something you know they you
know I don't know it's weird
um anyways just I'm not trying to this
is I ain't trying to be political about
this stuff I'm just saying you know do
do you today okay
anyway uh so what's been going on man I
haven't seen you guys in a couple weeks
live last week I put like a uh like sort
of crossover episode I wanted you guys
to get a taste of Jin to Gin uh but you
know from the numbers I don't think
people like it
it is what it is we got a new set and
everything on that so you gotta check
out newer episodes honestly
foreign
so anyways I went to Adam Ray's wedding
in
um where do we go it was in Arizona and
it was beautiful man
um
it really was uh we it was at this
really nice like Resort and the weather
weather was beautiful because normally
Phoenix is terrible right Phoenix is
terrible and
um
it's just too hot and like this is that
time of year where Phoenix was beautiful
so it was great Rachel and I had a
really good time and but here's the
thing that was like and a lot of comics
were there too Jeremiah Watkins Chris
Delia
um
uh Adam DeVine like it was so many
people like it was nice to see how many
people Harlan Williams it was nice to
see all the people that that is that
Adam Ray has touched you know and then
he had his mom was there his like
college roommate his college for
Fraternity guys like people from all
walks of life you know his Rabbi from
when he was a child was doing the
ceremony so it was great Rick Glassman
was there
um so we um
so here's the funny part for me so you
know I Rachel's Jewish okay so we had we
didn't have a Jewish wedding per se
because Rick Glassman who is Jewish but
he's not a rabbi was the officiant at
our wedding and it was a beautiful
wedding I I really had a good time in my
wedding so we did a few things like I
broke the glass so we did the circle
thing and Rick said a couple of things
that were like hey this is the things
you know the Jewish things we were
underneath the the what you call it I
forgot what it's called right
but Adam Ray's wedding oh it was Jewish
okay like I'm talking about there must
have been so many things and so I'm
sitting here and Rick is sitting next to
me so I'm looking over at Rick like yo
how come we didn't do that and he's like
I'm not a rabbi you know what I say okay
but I mean and then like one after the
other after the other and then I turned
to Rick and like am I even married
you know what I'm saying like am I even
married because I'm looking at this like
Adam went through all the stops man and
so but it was nice uh one of the things
I liked is that they his dick his wife
didn't come out to the traditional music
they actually came out to uh A Thousand
Years the Twilight song which I love
because if you guys know my podcast you
know I love Twilight
it was just love it so um
I loved that it was great music the grab
I was doing his singing thing there was
so many things where I was like wow this
is really
really nice and formal and uh
traditional Jewish wedding
um and then it was a great great um you
know food and you know we're outside the
food was great the setting everything
looked beautiful and then we go inside
right and then we're about to do the uh
you know he's doing we're doing they're
doing the dance dancing with the father
the mother then they're dancing and this
is a funny thing to happen
so
we're sitting there and we're looking at
them and I'm thinking about my own
wedding and I turn to Rachel and I go I
think our wedding was better and at that
moment
Adam goes up and announces everybody uh
you know here's my friend coming to sing
for our first dance John Resnick
straight up the lead singer from the Goo
Goo Dolls goes on stage with his guitar
and he you know he jams out to you know
the Goo Goo Dolls his famous song
they understand and the whole place is
like swaying and everybody's taking
videos and I'm just thinking to myself
well guess uh
point to Adam
you know what I mean I was like oh man
this dude this dude outdid me
but it was beautiful and then the dude
was having a great time like singing his
songs and then at the end because
everybody was singing the chorus at the
end and it was just like a great moment
and then the guy goes let's sing the
chorus again you know it was just like
you know and then he like you know so he
hopped on a private jet probably came to
the wedding sung the songs he sung like
two or three songs uh and then he was
like you know see you later and then he
had to go to the airport and get back on
a plane because he had he was doing
concerts so it was like
oh man it was funny it was it was great
so shout out to Adam for uh putting on a
really great wedding you know what I
mean had a really great time
so check out you know and Adam's doing a
lot of great stuff man he's in a bunch
of stuff he's going flat she's on he did
it he did a that Hulu show about Nixon
uh he's like you know he's on young Rock
Adam Ray is killing it he is killing it
and I'm so happy for him that he got
married to a beautiful lady Amanda's
great so shout out to Amanda and Adam
Ray
excuse me
okay guys uh we gotta get to it cause
like I gotta get going
but it is what it is you know I love
doing my riffing with Griffin and again
once again I appreciate you all for
being here so let's get into some some
delicate stuff well I don't know if it's
delicate but it's just it is what it is
it's like currently what's going on
right now so
we got this uh
Kyrie Irving situation it's been going
on for like two weeks now and
I said you know I want to speak on it
first it's nuanced I haven't used this
word in a while but it's a nuanced
situation
uh because as things unfold you deal
with it you're supposed to deal with it
as they happen
uh taking some things into the past into
account but also taking what's happening
currently into account and that I think
that's important to have Grace and
empathy for everybody involved
so first of all I thought in the
beginning of the season I thought Kyrie
Irving was doing a great job he was
playing great and he was speaking with
the media in a way that you go oh I
think this guy's going to turn a corner
he was you know
carrying himself in a way but you know
because he got money on the line it's a
contract year and all the baggage that
he brings the the Nets were like we're
not going to resign you for any
long-term deal so he was probably going
to be done with the Nets anyway or he
was going to have to prove that he could
play 82 games or at least close to that
and contribute without all this off the
court drama and then boom drops the bomb
so he tweets out this movie that has
these sort of anti-Semitic tropes in it
I haven't seen the movie I'm not going
to say the title of the movie I'm never
gonna watch the movie I mean if I was a
journalist or something I mean I'm a
podcaster you know I'm just speaking my
mind you know what I mean you know I
don't know you take whatever what you
want but I'm not gonna watch this movie
because you know it normally normally in
these kind of situations too because
it's kind of it's a weird vibe in the
world right now when it comes to like
social media and sensitivity and cancer
culture so you got you got to take
things with a grain of salt sometimes
you know somebody says oh this is racist
this is whatever you sometimes you got
to take a pause and be like well is it
you know then maybe you look at it for
yourself and then you go yes or no right
and maybe these people just being too
sensitive there is a lot of that going
on in the world unfortunately I think
it's an unfortunate thing because now
you can't trust anybody right
but I'm gonna say this
I have to trust the people that have
looked at this have have you know take
done their investigating the defamation
league and all the places that have
looked into this movie and they've put
out you know these are reputable
organizations that are like look this
isn't this has a lot of anti-Semitism in
it and that's so I had to trust them on
that okay
so then Kyrie Irving tweets out this
movie because it has that in it but I
think in his mind it also has some other
stuff in it that is not negative towards
Jewish people right but that doesn't
mean it's okay you can't discount the
other part of it you know what I mean
it's like Farrakhan was like that
Farrakhan you might listen to Farrakhan
give a speech and he'll be saying some
stuff and you find yourself going okay
that makes sense and then he'll say and
the Jews and then you go ah come on man
then you just go it discounts everything
you know no matter it no matter even if
you make a good point if there's any
hate in it then it's like you take away
from it so why have that you know
anyways so Kyrie Irving tweets out this
movie all right so that's the first
mistake okay
now I don't know Kyrie Irving I don't
know the whole situation in terms of
like how this all played out but I'm
gonna give you my personal opinion of
what I think happened I think that I
don't think he even saw the movie
honestly
I think that I think that he may know
the filmmakers or know someone that
knows the filmmakers or you know and he
just like and somebody was saying yo man
this movie got you know this Positive
Black message and and this kind of stuff
and and he and he just stupidly and
unwittingly just was like oh oh yeah I
like that boom and put it and tweeted it
out you can't do that when you that
famous you can't
you just can't you know what I mean when
you a public figure that
um you know where the people are
involved in Commerce you know people
that buy tickets people that you know
you selling merchandise you you it's a
commercial business you can't just
irresponsibly put out whatever you want
on sadly right
or I don't even know how to even say
that anyways and maybe he did see it and
then he just was like ignored that part
of it in his arrogance because that's an
arrogant dude Kyrie Irving is an
arrogant dude and I'm gonna get into
that so
he puts this out right
now people get on them they're like yo
this has this so now this is where he
mishandled this completely okay he
mishandled this
wait even before I talk about that let
me talk about this for a second as I
said to you earlier my wife is Jewish
I love her
this is different for me now I'm married
into the tribe right I love her family
like I never had a big family before
I've never I my family is so I have I'm
I'm
estranged from my family because of a
lot of like personal things and it's
like crazy I've never experienced having
a big family and all of a sudden I've
married into this family all the cousins
are great uh that you know they we text
each other and it's like a thing where
I've never experienced before
and I love these people you know and so
then now I have when I hear when I see
all this hate
you know towards a group
when you're not even considering that
these are individuals these are people
who have lives and families and they're
just like you just because you disagree
with or you have some weird thing about
where someone's from I mean to me it
just feels stupid it feels stupid racism
feels stupid you know and then on top of
race anyway so I have my own feelings of
like how am I supposed to speak about
this how am I supposed to you know it
sucks so anytime I see this kind of like
hatred and then you Google like man
there's not a lot of Jews in the world
anymore just that this is a tribe of
people that you know went through some
horrific stuff and now they're just
trying to live and survive apparently
apparently there are more Jews in
Brooklyn than there are in Israel that
says a lot about how many Jews are in
Brooklyn and also how little there are
in the entire world anyways that being
said
so getting back to it
um you know he puts out this movie and
then the people are getting on I'm like
yo bro this thing is terrible it's it's
you know and how he handled it was just
terrible and it's all about pride and
ego you know and I get that as a comic
as a comic when like say I have a joke I
do and then somebody comes and says like
oh you hate women or you that's racist
or you you're transphobic or you're
you're you know you you hate whatever
right as a as a comic you get offended
I'm like no I don't you you don't
understand a joke that's the initial
reaction you know
and so
but at least my intent or even maybe his
intent was like he really thought that
this was like okay the other parts of it
and it discounted it it it like
outweighed the the Sandy semitism I just
don't believe he even looked at the
movie that's what I believe really I
think that's why this is really stupid
so I get the the sort of visceral
reaction to be like nah you don't you
don't know me right and so
but he's such a public figure that he
should all he had to do was just be like
you know what didn't realize this was
like this wasn't my intention to offend
anyone I'm deeply sorry for you know
that's what you do okay mean it or not
people were hurt
you know this people were hurt okay
people were like yo man you know Jewish
people like yeah we buy tickets you know
to the Nets you know like well you
coming off like anyways
he didn't do that
and he's never he's like just sort of
like aloof like uh how can I be
anti-semic anti-semitic when I know who
I am [__] just apologize you
know what I mean like put your [__]
ego aside and just apologize and that's
what he couldn't do he just couldn't do
it he couldn't do it until the Nets
themselves suspended him and then he was
like oh [__] money's on the line whoa
I'm in a contract here I'm about to like
my career is about to be in Jeopardy oh
now let me apologize it comes off
transparent and it comes off
disingenuous I mean when he could have
just and but you know he he felt
pressured he felt like
you know he took a stand where he
shouldn't and this is who he is so this
is my problem with the whole thing
I have a problem with how he dealt with
it but at the same time this is who he
is this is the guy that put out the
Earth is flat for whatever reason he was
saying this is the guy that was like you
know
he he got hurt in college didn't play a
lot he was in trouble before LeBron
James got there LeBron James is so great
he he overcame all that got the best out
of Kyrie they won a championship but
then in the end you heard all these
Rumblings out of Cleveland that he was
difficult to deal with okay they trade
him he goes to Boston at Boston he ruins
that situation he was he was not a good
teammate it didn't work out he says I'm
coming back he doesn't that situation
blunders he goes to the Nets okay now
he's at the Nets all right he he he he
doesn't play then the pandemic hits
right the pandemic hits and he decides
well I'm not gonna go play in the bubble
I don't he's telling people not to play
in the bubble then he's like I don't
want to play without Kevin once Kevin
Durant decides to go there he's like
well I don't want to play with y'all I
want to wait for Kevin Durant to come he
doesn't play meanwhile making 30
something million dollars a year right
always and then January 6 happens and
he's like I can't go to work and then
he's caught going to parties with his
sister okay he's at a family party
instead of playing basketball that he's
getting paid to do then the vaccine
vaccination comes and he's like I don't
want to get vaccinated okay even though
you know and that's his right right
that's his right to be to be that way
but at the same time you know he put
this you know he he let his teammates
down his teammates were like well we're
going to do it because we want to play
we want to win you know this is what we
want to do and he's like nah he takes
some weird stance for people
by the way he wasn't wrong about
what he was saying I just don't know if
he went about it the right way but like
I say that's your right okay
because it turns out in New York had
this crazy mandate that you know public
workers had to be uh vaccinated so a lot
of like firemen policemen people like
that left their jobs
forced out sort of but now they sued and
they got reinstated and with back pay
because it wasn't right so that's what
I'm saying how it's nuanced
what Kyrie Irving's intentions I don't
know if they were genuine but what he
was saying was right okay so again it's
I I can be I can have a comment about
his choice to not get vaccinated because
he wasn't playing I can be I I could be
like I think he should have got
vaccinated and played but I haven't but
I respect your right that's your choice
right
so you had that drama okay and then now
cut to this this is the latest drama
it doesn't translate to winning
I don't know they should just cut ties
with him let him play or cut ties with
him okay so there you have that all
right so that's why this happening is
compounded because of who he is and his
history
now cut to the next organization super
dysfunctional organization
they fired the coach when Kyrie Irving
and Kevin Durant got there the dude that
was winning
he got the best out of those guys
they even made the playoffs right Kenny
Atkins and then they fired him because
Kyrie and what Scott you know they they
did this like we don't need a coach
right they hire Steve Nash okay so then
cut to now no one's there's no
accountability with the Nets so Kyrie
Irving decides not to get vaccinated
then New York has this weird thing where
uh if you the home team can't play
unless they're vaccinated but people
from from out of state can come in and
work whether they're vaccinated or not
that was stupid but they make a choice
and they go all right Kyrie if you're
not going to get vaccinated you can't
play that's just you know that's the
rules you're not getting paid sit out he
was like fine he lost like 17 million
dollars but then they caved on it then
they said all right now you can play
because you know we're trying to win
that was weak they should have just
stuck to their guns and dealt with him
at the end of the season how they what
are they gonna do that was weak all
right so then
so then you cut to with the Nets also
you have Kevin Durant who was like trade
me after he already signed a four-year
deal he's like trade me so he goes and
then they don't trade him because they
can't get equal value and then why would
he want to go to a team that they have
to gut just to have him now he can't win
a championship with that team so they
don't trade him then he says okay I'll
come back if you fire the GM and Steve
Nash the coach right
Josiah the owner is like no I'm not
going to do that you know he tweets out
like I support my guys cut two seven
games into the season this Kyrie Irving
thing breaks out they fire Steve Nash
like this organization is the worst so
now we're coming to what weird reason
why I'm talking about this you got a
dysfunctional organization you got an
arrogant billionaire owner you got Kyrie
Irving this aloof dude who thinks he's
smarter than everybody you have him and
his arrogance and pride and they're
going heads up against each other
because this is what's happening right
now that I don't agree with so now Kyrie
Irving has apologized
he was wrong he waited too long it's not
a good look it comes across as arrogant
and prideful he apologizes he offers 500
000 to the defamation League or whatever
uh organization that is let's match it
okay and now he's just like then this
the Nets go we're gonna suspend you for
five games okay the dude made a mistake
he's come out publicly finally like look
I'm not anti-semitic you know I just
think he made a mistake and he didn't
want to admit it it was arrogant people
got hurt there should be a punishment
they did it now the Nets are talking
about there's this six point six steps
he has to make do to come back to the
organization
think it's too much I feel like they're
pouring it on he apologized he's paying
to find he's losing money because he the
five game suspension the guy makes 40
million dollars so you know that's a lot
of money per game I think that's enough
if you don't want him around your
organization anymore because he's too
toxic then you trade him cut him tell
him to stay home we'll pay you stay home
but what they're doing right now is too
much and now the league has to step in
the Players Association and the Players
Association they represent the players
regardless regardless of whatever
happens that's their job is to represent
the player so now they got to step in
and be like yo look we don't necessarily
agree with uh what Kyrie did but y'all
y'all can't treat them like this so you
got this billionaire owner and then
Kyrie Irving also that's his boss the
dude was like Kyrie Irving from reports
ignored him for three or four days you
can't do that
a dude's paying you 40 million dollars
you answer his calls
period right
so I just think it's a bucket of heads
going on right now that it's gonna now
it's the situation is now he gonna be
made even worse because the ego and
pride the whole thing's nuanced man it's
nuance
and and it's it's getting worse because
now if you go hey I'm not supporting
Kyrie Irving and what he did but I do
support the idea that like you can't
just treat people now like this because
you want to pour it on and then now
you're gonna have people being like oh
well that means you support
anti-Semitism no you don't this is
nuanced this could be picked apart it's
a terrible situation from a
dysfunctional organization and a dude
that is like something's not a hundred
percent going on right in this dude's
head man and that's been going on now
for a while and it might be time for it
might be time for the NBA to cut ties
with Kyrie Irving but you can't just
treat a dude like this you know he made
a mistake he's trying to pay for it
let's move on or
or you know like I said get rid of him
or let him play one or the other so I
don't I want to know what you guys have
to say about it uh let's have a good
discourse about it and see you know
where we can go I love to respond to
people but let's do it now that being
said because this gets into my next
subject I want to talk about which is
um
where is it which is now
uh wait oops wait I've got to do this
this is when it's all me by myself you
know what I mean wait come on now come
on Griffin there we go our next subject
is Mr musk buying Twitter
now let me say this man as I say I would
love a healthy discourse I love that
there's a sentiment out in the universe
the online universe that
I'm supposed to allow
negativity on my personal social media
channels and channels
I'm just gonna dispel that right now
I adamantly disagree with that premise
okay I disagree with this premise that
oh like when somebody goes man why are
you uh limiting your comments that's a
bad look no it's not no it's not
I this is my [__]
on my YouTube channel if I don't want
your nonsense on my channel it's not
gonna be on my Channel That's My
Prerogative that's my right especially
the way people do it like it's like if
you disagree with me right now about
like Kyrie or you have your own thoughts
you don't have to Pepper that with oh
you fat idiot oh you're stupid or you
you know all this like extra adjectives
to the things that you want to say just
be like yo Griff I disagree here's what
I think and then I could be like oh man
I feel you here's what I think to that
what happened to that what happened to
like productive positive discourse
between two people but no it just
becomes a thing where people just want
to be negative and nasty see y'all don't
get it I get a lot of nasty hate from
people and I'm at the point now I'm like
nah I don't want that on my channel like
so if you're one of these people out
there just like oh uh why are you hiding
comments because I don't like what you
have to say
period it's my [__] this is my Fife term
right here I don't need your negativity
on my channel and so and then here's
what I do I don't even block people I
normally do not block people I just hide
so that way when you go to your YouTube
channel and you're looking at my
comments you see your comment because
it's for you
but I don't want that from my people and
my eyes see ya same thing on Instagram I
restrict I had two things I do on
Instagram I have
I have it where you have to be my friend
to comment so there are people that come
to my page who want to hate they just
immediately come and like you stupid and
then it goes oh man I can't even comment
oh why are you being a coward no no
you're just you're not a fan
you know what I mean like you have to
follow me [__] just follow me write your
negativity and then unfollow and then I
know oh restrict and then once you're
restricted you can't put any comments I
get these messages people like oh man
why you're comments restricted and then
like expletive expletive expletive and
I'm just like because of this that's why
now that being said how am I why am I
talking about this in terms of this guy
it's because here's the thing I feel
like all of you all of us have the right
to be like hey I just want positivity on
my social media all right even if you
say some things that are like ridiculous
it's your right to be like well I only
want people that agree with me to be on
my thing that's fine what I don't like
though is when the companies are the
ones that make those choices
that's when I have a problem
you know because then you're going well
who's making this choice
like Instagram's on this nonsense man
with like it's some sort of computer AI
like I'll give you an example I play
Call of Duty I play
um you know I play video games so I'm
playing Call of Duty so there was a
video I saw and the dude did this
incredible play and then the vernacular
of like when you're talking about video
games you call somebody sweaty when you
call somebody sweaty it means they're
really good you know and they're like
they're just like taking advantage of
the game mechanics and they're really
good so I was like oh man you sweaty
[__] right that's a positive comment
but the Instagram AI picks that up it's
like you're being negative and boom boom
boom you're just like oh wow so the
human element is being taken out of it
completely and so now we have to only
talk in a certain way
uh you know you know what I mean uh you
know you know you mentioned the word you
mentioned I'm not even gonna say it
because that's what's gonna happen you
mentioned a disease or well I already
did anyway so don't matter you say covet
or vaccination all of a sudden the
algorithm picks that up and all of a
sudden on your videos on your on your
Instagram there's some thing about you
know misinformation and make sure boom
boom and you're like whoa hold on a
second hold on a second there's no human
beings actually doing that because what
I don't appreciate is you know you will
you will they will do this for covid but
they won't do it for allegations they
won't do it for like people saying rude
negative things
I just you know what I mean so
I don't appreciate when like the
organization itself is they're they're
like police and morality yes there are
hate speech and things that it just we
we just can't have it in society but
then there's a level where you just go
like who's making this choice I think it
should be like you know like I say on
your on your thing I'm totally okay with
anybody being like I don't want no
negativity on my page Channel whatever
this is just from this is my social
media I want to be social and I want to
be social not like I'm a sort of a
public figure and I'm doing a podcast
like this so I do allow some discourse
all I'm saying is if you're gonna have
some negativity in it if there's going
to be some personal attacks on me you
out [__] bye and and I'm and if you
have a problem with that hey middle
finger's up to you too so that's just
how that's gonna go so now cut to what
I'm talking about now Elon Musk the deal
went through and he's bought Twitter
this is my personal opinion on this
this is the dumbest
vanity purchase
ever
44 billion dollars for a product that I
don't think
people really use all that much
I think there's a lot of bots on it the
engagement is super low like if you have
a thousand followers and you get 10
likes it's like well are these people
even seeing this who's even on it
some studies
some studies they're talking about the
certain age group The Millennials are
whatever that age group like under 35
whatever it is it's only 25 of them even
use Twitter
like if he had called
um if he had bought Tick Tock man that'd
be a whole different thing right because
that has the most engagement apparently
Tick Tock just passed Google for the
most searches so I mean then you talk
about well here's something that's
really influential I just don't know if
Twitter is all that influential anymore
do you even tweet are you guys tweeting
like who's still Tweeting like who still
gets information from Twitter like I
would like to know what you guys think
about that
um
uh and and by the way so I see there's
an idiot in chat already you know so I
challenged this already I have never
banned people
for
criticizing my point of view
I I just said to you so now this guy
wants this is a I'm so glad you did this
because this is a perfect example right
here guys write in chat so the guy
starts it off with an insult Eric is too
soft
is that needed in this thing is that
needed is that part of it needed you
know I I don't ban anyone for insults if
you make me laugh if you want to call me
fat or whatever it is and you construct
that in a funny joke I'll be the first
person that laughs see you don't know me
like that and you're a coward I'm right
here on Front Street my name is Eric
Griffin you can email me you can even
come see me live and come approach me
and be like yo man I didn't like but
you're coward we don't even know who you
really are that's not even your real
name so you out here keyboard warrioring
like like you're you're saying something
prolific or profound you're not you just
did what I just said
you started off your comment with an
insult and it's not necessary does
anybody does everybody see what I'm
saying is that part of what he said
necessary no it's not necessary I'm all
for discourse go to my comments section
if somebody said something to me that
they're like whatever I respond right
back and we have a good back and forth
[__] like this bye
okay
okay so now we'll never see that that
guy again all right so we moved on you
see what I'm saying
that's exactly what I'm talking about
I think I'm so I'm actually so glad that
that guy came into the chat because it's
perfect
you know I'm this is for fun man I'm
having fun I'm getting my point of view
out some people like my point of view so
that's why they listen to people that
disagree with my point of view you come
at me and be like yeah man I disagree
with that but I appreciate this or that
like let's just have a a positive
discourse that's all I want okay let me
say again you wanna you wanna make fun
of me and you want to make a joke make a
joke I'm all for jokes I'm a comic okay
make jokes but if you coming at me with
insults I don't want you here
see you later and then the people that
say don't give them attention no it has
to be pointed out for the rest of y'all
okay the rest of y'all so we can know
how we can make it better
all right anyways so Elon buys this
Twitter I think it's a stupid purchase
man I really do I don't you know and
then all the the things that are going
on he's trying to like
have a paywall
I don't know if I'm gonna do it I
haven't really decided yet because I was
thinking do I use Twitter I I just don't
tweet anymore and when I do tweet it's
like oh here's here's my show or here's
my podcast and I don't even know how
much engagement you know you really get
on that you know let's see let me go to
my Twitter right now man I'm going to
Twitter oh you know what let's do it
like this
you know you know you go to Twitter
let's see if this is working yeah you go
to Twitter right so let's say uh you
know
you know you you know you look at your
your page right you go to your profile
you know I have like 68 000 followers
that's not a lot in the grand scheme of
things and like for instance I just
tweeted out my podcast I got three three
likes like like this is Twitter's not
even you know like I put out this
stand-up video that I have right now
which you gotta check out uh shout out
to Comedy Dynamics
you know I have this uh uh the clip I
put out 15 likes but on Instagram I got
like 70 000 views and I've got a
thousand likes and you know I just don't
think like Twitter people are even
engaged in Twitter anymore
uh so I just don't know if
what like what is the the purpose I I
just I it would be one thing if it was
like this is the kind of thing oh man
it's going and going Twitter's the kind
of thing you just hear about people are
are upset about things you know
here's how what I think about social
media even in general
and and like we can apply this also to
the Kyrie Irving situation
the internet doesn't make you famous
the internet actually is anti-fame
and I'll tell you why I feel that way
the internet goes like this
hey y'all
look at that guy look at this girl look
at this thing and then we all go okay
now it's up to that person
entity
to keep our attention
we look at it and we go oh
but what ends up happening after that is
it has to keep going and keep going so
it is relied upon that person now to
rise to the occasion
off the the Internet by the way
so
what ends up happening is the only
reason why we say follow someone
or we keep them attention on the
Internet is because of what they're
doing off the internet
so like if it's a comic you think
they're funny so you go watch them
perform live
and you you know you watch their podcast
or you you know whatever that is and
then you you keep doing it because they
keep they keep making you feel like Oh I
like that person I like that person but
it's not the internet it really is the
person so cut to Kyrie Irving
who won a championship he was in Uncle
Drew so he was
popular because of those things
but then
he hasn't done anything of significance
since in terms of like why we even like
him it's because he plays basketball
but he plays basketball individually
well but it doesn't lead to winning and
that's all we really care about in terms
of
when we see an influencer
if not ask yourself
in the basketball world
do you want to hear things from really
like there's very few basketball players
that I go oh let me follow this guy
because of his political beliefs or
because of his movie recommendations or
maybe there's a few basketball players
that you go oh I like this guy because
he does this other thing like there's a
few players that game right you might be
like oh that dude's a good gamer so
that's why I'm but the only reason why
you watching the gaming is because what
he's a famous basketball player but then
it gets into a thing where you go well I
don't know if I want to hear
personal opinions or you may not want to
hear it right you barely want to hear it
from a comic but the nature of what
comedy is is we analyze things and talk
about them we try to make them funny
right like my podcast is like I just
when I'm doing solo like this I just I
tend to just be serious you know but
like when I'm on other podcasts and you
you watch me like oh he's good with
other people and that's why people are
like Griff you need a co-host but this
is for me too I like doing this I like
having a place where I could just like
get this out that's why I want to have a
discourse with people right so you know
anyways what basketball players do we
really go oh let's hear there's only one
really if you think about it LeBron
James is the only basketball player that
we go all right we're going to listen to
some of the things that he says he has
influence outside of basketball but the
only reason why he has that influence is
because he's arguably the greatest
player ever
if he wasn't we wouldn't care so that
that's what I'm saying so like LeBron
James is about to go away okay he's
he is about to retire in the next few
years and when he's not that basketball
player anymore I don't know if we're
going to want to hear anything he has to
say after that he might transition into
being a mogul you know he might turn
into like you know where he's got uh you
know music companies and all that stuff
that we might go okay uh like Mark Cuban
or somebody we'll be like oh then he'll
have that influence but it's because
he's rich and it's not because of the
internet you know what I'm saying like
the internet exposes people the internet
exposes you and if you don't keep it up
then we're like then people start to
look at a person and go like that's
what's happening with Kyrie Irving we
looking at him like yo bro I don't we
don't really care can you win can you go
play basketball now because
it's not going well and we start to
realize what is the reasons why we even
listen to people you know and then you
have like you know anyways so that's
what I'm saying it's like anti-fame so
Elon it feels like now he's out here
tweeting constantly he's out here
tweeting he's out here making fun of
people he's out here like I mean I guess
if you were a billionaire I guess you do
the same thing like you're a billionaire
and this is your platform and you out
here just going at it yeah it's gonna be
eight dollars a month oh you can say
whatever you want but it's gonna cost
you eight dollars he made he that just
tweet about Kathy Griffin
you know that she got her her account
got suspended you know and somebody was
like oh Kathy account got suspended
because she was pretending to be Elon
Musk and then he tweeted no she got
suspended for pretending to be a
comedian or something like that right it
was like a sick burn but it's like damn
he owns the company
so now now here's what I'm saying he's
in a tough situation because what if
people start coming at him is he if he
is he gonna start removing people
because of that that's gonna be that's
gonna take away it's weird it's gonna
take away the Integrity of Twitter
itself like I don't mind if Elon like
blocks people from his personal Twitter
account
but if he
like it's a weird thing because like how
do you determine why things are
happening so it's like I
I just don't know guys I don't know how
this is gonna play out but just
originally why I'm even talking about
this is
I just I don't think this was a good
purchase
so you could tell me why you think it's
a good purchase I'd love to see in the
comments I just don't think Twitter is
all that important I don't think it's
real I think that you know you hear
about people being like outraged on
Twitter and then you hear about it and
then you look and then nothing happens
like nothing really happens you know
occasionally stuff happens because if
there's real world consequences like
Kyrie Irving it's real world
consequences you know it's not because
of the Internet it's not because of
cancer culture it's not because of like
no it's like he did something that like
it's gonna affect the Bottom Line it's
gonna you know a a large group of people
who were insulted I mean it's you know
what I'm saying but it the internet just
like a tool but it's not the reason
so I don't know
I just I just don't know I don't know I
really want to know what you guys think
to me like I say to me this was the
dumbest vanity purchase ever it's like a
dude buying like million dollar Yeezys
you know with like diamond crusted and
he's like it's just a floss like yo look
look at my Yeezys now they have
collector's item and you know and it is
you know you go okay why'd you spend a
million dollars on shoes when you're a
billionaire you spend this amount of
money on
something like this man and you're just
like
whoa this is a lot you know what I mean
it's a lot so I don't know
I just I don't know
um
yeah that's all I really have to say
about that I would love to hear what you
guys have to say in your comments about
it
you think it's a great purchase you
think like Twitter's Gonna Change the
World or something I think if Twitter
was going to change it would already
have it already would have I just think
that people move on fast we go from uh
Friendster to Myspace to Instagram to
tick tock Twitter sprinkled in there
what's the next thing going to be I just
think that that's felt like a lot of
money and I don't think it was necessary
I I just maybe I'm wrong maybe he's
gonna like put the pay platform and
maybe it's gonna you know this whole
idea of free speech and all this stuff
is fine you know people like to throw
Around The Words Free Speech not
realizing that Free Speech also means
that the people can respond with free
speech too you know that's the thing you
know that's the people need to remember
they I have free speech to say this and
you have free speech to disagree and
then I have free speech to disagree with
your disagreement and it goes on and on
and on and on and on it's just I think
that shouldn't be peppered with insults
and um
you know
negativity doesn't have to be negative
you know what I mean it doesn't have to
be negative
right
uh
anyways
like I say
um yeah anyways whatever that's it with
that because I gotta go soon uh I just
want to talk about normally I wanted to
do this thing where I recap you know how
I like to recap movies
you know uh I'm not gonna do it with
this one I wanted to because it's like
man I saw this movie recommended by a
friend of mine you know
um oh man look at my green screen isn't
working well you guys see that I don't
like that why is it look like that you
know if you're listening live you know
you're gonna
I mean if you're listening you're gonna
be like what's he talking about you know
let's see if I can fix that a little bit
wait wait wait
there we go boom
yeah yeah look how I fixed that so I saw
this movie it's like a Dutch movie It's
called speak no evil
um
yes got subtitles but it's still in a
lot of it's in English
it's about a Danish family visits a a
Danish family visits a Dutch family they
met on a holiday what was supposed to be
in a nice weekend slowly turns or starts
unravel it unravels into some horrific
let me let me tell you guys something
this is the most
horrific movie I've ever seen in my life
the ending it's a slow burn
it's a slow burn slow build up where you
just kind of be like whoa that's weird
oof what's going on there
and it just goes and goes to this
terrifying horrific moment that I wish
I'd never seen
so
I am recommending this movie
foreign
I'm recommending it and at the same time
saying don't watch it
do what this is like this is like
remember the ring that you know like the
ring and this is like Jeremiah Watkins I
gotta I gotta give him credit for this
joke because we were talking about this
he said this to me too it's like
remember when you the ring you know in
the ring like you passed this video on
and when you see it you got seven days
and somebody else has to watch it or
you're gonna die that's how I feel about
what this movie is this movie
man I'm telling you
it's just what happens in the end of
this movie
whoo so what I'm doing right now is I'm
giving a shout out to the movie because
I think next week I'm gonna do a
complete recap of the movie so this is
like spoiler alert for next week and I'm
just gonna recap the whole movie and
tell you everything that happens so this
is just like
the beginnings of it so you know like
get yourself prepared for this because
this [__] is going to be scary all right
um
anyways
let me see uh let me let me let me get
this
let me get this going here because
that's going to be the episode y'all but
I gotta get you know my music for the
rap recap you know
you know me I'm not here doing my thing
out here ripping and rapping you know
what I'm saying so let me see which one
oh here we go this is a good this is a
good beat so ladies and gentlemen I do
want to thank you for watching riffing
with Griffin
um and make sure you uh you know
subscribe all that stuff share
yeah
it's the rap recap
here we go with the sick ass flow
now you know
I don't regular joke
check out the flow make sure you
subscribe and share I know that you
don't care
strive to stay alive
Twitter
[Music]
it ain't a hitter I think it's a [__]
I'm about to quit her if I have to pay
eight dollars
everybody holla
that's about it
Eric Griffin is the [__]
he won't come back
[Music]
speak no evil was horrific
maybe it was terrific
thanks for being here
[Music]
in your ears
here
glad you were here
now I gotta go Eric Griffin with that
flow
s
foreign